what about you have you made progress in
caring about
whether people listen
to yourself
you made progress in caring about I
don't know about what people think about
it I think what people think about me
yes yes I have made progress it would be
I'd be lying if I said it didn't bother
me at all what people think about me but
I've made a lot of progress right yeah I
would say this but the cycle is also
shorter now yes oh my God I said the
wrong thing those people probably hate
me now they probably don't they probably
give me the benefit of the doubt over
yes that helps me because I think I've
made similar progress
in that way I used to worry
too much and I if you had asked me 10
years ago what's one thing you would
change about yourself I would say I
would I would very much like to not care
what people think of me yeah even today
coming in I saw Andy then I saw Jeff
Ross and
five years ago I would have gone oh I'm
gonna say hi but they don't want to talk
to me they have stuff to do they're
annoyed they have to talk to me they're
annoyed they have to talk to me and now
I walk in I'm annoyed to talk to them
and you should be she was really on the
other point John Mulaney I'm not
submitting writer package yeah Jeff Ross
anymore I don't know if it should no
well first of all you should never have
been submitting writer packets to Jeff
Ross which I think Jeff looked pretty
good that was it seems like it's typed
it's got words on it giving them to
Frank Smiley was that not the right guy
to go to Frank Smiley's Frank smiley
yeah but you still he shouldn't have
been submitting a writer back into him
either I think you're getting him to Dan
Blair and prop I think I think your
approach was all wrong all right that's
why I didn't get the big gig I submitted
three packets to that fire outside I
didn't get this thing I don't understand
what happened
30 Rock or was it 50 Rock new I
explicit instructions
these are my ideas ma'am deliver them to
Mr O'Brien
you're at a dental hygienist office
these go to Conan O'Brien uh do you care
what people think about you less as you
get older yes yeah I still care but I
care less yeah because I know
that I'm just gonna go away crumble turn
to Ash
how do you really deal with it don't do
a bit
don't do a bit don't do a bit about how
you deal with it uh how I deal with what
exactly let's get let's talk about it
death or criticism no how you deal with
whether you think people like you or not
well I've talked about this before I do
a bit actually this is
wow
there it is
no ah
I've mentioned this a couple times
before but when I was a kid I wrote EB
white a letter and he wrote me back and
in his return letter in a spider web he
wrote it he wrote it in spider web we
just had to do it didn't you just had to
do it
goddamn Pig just from the guy that
lectured me let's hear the real story
Conan that's the real story I didn't say
I wasn't going to do bits oh that's true
you never agreed to that never
uh anyway his response was what was your
letter to him saying uh well I can only
deduce that from reading his return
letter because it was so many years ago
but
um uh and since then the EB white like
Foundation has found the letter but whoa
uh anyway he says in it he says some
nice things about my letter and then he
says as for your question if you're
concerned about criticism if you're
going to have a tough go as a writer
because I was telling him I was
interested in writing and but you wanted
no criticisms I need a very long I I
know I'm telling you this is what I was
worried about was being criticized I
said I don't handle criticism very well
I'm afraid of it and he was basically
telling me you need to get over that
um I'm going to die soon and you're
going to be a talk show host anyway
you're never going to be a writer of no
pivot away from writing yeah as soon as
you can as soon as you can and squander
it in a foolish medium uh so that's what
I know that it was near and dear to my
heart and uh
I'm not gonna lie though I think if
someone has the wrong impression of me
it's hurtful but I uh as you go on I
think as you know when you have kids
things I think having kids is a huge
reset because you think well as long as
they're okay then yep there's that and
also you know I was like
oh I've met the person I I've I now know
the person that I want to make laugh and
uh
uh like the only you know it's not the
only I like other people in my life but
if there's someone's eyes I want to see
light up it's his my son when I get home
so yeah it does and all my anxieties are
poured into him as well in a good way I
think yeah and also being a parent's
made me dumb so my thoughts are
extremely simple and they're just kind
of on a 20 month old level and that has
made me one thousand times happier are
you funny to a almost two-year-old very
yeah and I am phenomenal at baseball
team
hahaha
I can hit a baseball far that you
wouldn't believe how far I can hit a
wiffle ball
he has said things like whoa
and Dada do that yeah yeah I do I do
remember uh I think it was my
maybe it was my daughter when she was
like two or three watching me sink some
baskets and seeing her face think he's
maybe the greatest athlete that's ever
lived just picturing you bringing her in
a stroller to a public court in New York
City yeah and then you stand at the free
throw line I'm taking shot after shot
she was in the Sun
and I there's a little thing that you
can a little hood that you can pull over
but I didn't do it because I thought it
would obscure her view of my shots
and the fact that I made two out of 11
uh impressed her and then she was very
sick from heat stroke but the point is
I'm a really good guy
no I can't even
um think past yeah is my I used to spin
out about so many things and I used to
want to be so clever and wanted to be
this curated little prick and I now have
nothing in my head except yeah Malcolm
do that all right yeah baseball he wakes
up he wakes up at 4 50 a.m every night
when he goes to bed I go what time are
you gonna wake up and he goes seven and
we both laugh
and then he goes we say deal and we
shake and he gets in bed wakes up at 4
50. I unzip him at 450. this happened
two Wednesdays ago and he goes baseball
immediately I go you want to play
because game so I take him out get him
out of his sleep sack now he and I are
in the front yard 5 10 a.m in pajamas
and jackets and I take the ball and I
put it on the tee and he's holding a
wiffle ball bat and he goes two bats so
I hand him another bet now he has two
then I had to buy a third because when
we play he likes two bets so I need mine
I put the ball on and he goes that I do
and I go Dad I do I smack that Wiffle
ball so far and he goes yeah good job
yeah good job I put a ball on for him
and I go Malcolm do that he goes yeah
Malcolm do that and he hits the ball
which is means he hits his hand holding
the bat against the T and the ball falls
off sure and I go yeah good job he goes
yeah good job Malcolm good job and we're
just two morons at five in the morning
the floodlights are like ring camera
lights are going off it's so early the
way he's saying baseball it makes it
sound like he wants to like does it
sound like he wants to bet on baseball
oh yeah yeah
baseball yeah
yeah baseball he came from a time
machine to bed
yes as we all did like I
a big a big thing for me now is I used
to need so much to feel any kind of
happiness in the day and if I see a
garbage truck with him now we're both so
psyched it's like seeing a celebrity we
hide behind a garbage can and we watch
it like in odd silence like we're two
women who see Courtney Cox at The Grove
we just walked Barefoot still in pajamas
and jackets following the garbage truck
holding Wiffle ball back and you look at
the thing come out and grab that yeah no
one impersonates a garbage truck better
than me in my son's eyes
and he goes
now at home you can yell garbage truck
all day long that's something you yell
like if you got into water and it's cold
yeah garbage truck
when you're following the garbage truck
he and I have never discussed this but
we have a mutual understanding you do
not yell garbage truck at the garbage
truck like that would be disrespectful
yes there's an etiquette there's some
strange understood There's a garbage
truck yes
and he understands that yeah so I'm a
bad interview these days and I'm not as
fun to talk to at parties because
everything's so simplified both loving
my son and being on his level if this is
a bad interview
then uh I wish all my interviews were
just oh how kind
be real for a second I am no that was
awful no that was Dreadful what you just
did that was Dreadful
thank you
um he said it like a horse
[Laughter]
fine
uh I'm gonna wrap this up but I am going
to tell you
something I've told you before which is
uh you are a constant source of uh uh I
don't know joy to me anyway I just
absolutely love what you do and I've
said this before I love your mind and
your writing and uh your performing of
comedy and it makes me feel good about
things and about the way stuff is headed
and uh I am so happy for you that you're
finding peace and having a good time
thanks man with uh with your family
and it's a nice day for me when I get to
sit here and trade stupidity with you
it's a joy for me thank you Conan you're
my absolute hero so you saying that
means more than I can say in words
as a horse
[Laughter]
all right thank you sir thank you